الاخر طبعا هو كانت اشكاليه كان يعني
العلاقه مع الاخر كانت اشكاليه من
اشكاليات
الازمه ازمه الصح لكن الذي حدث الان انا
اعيبه كثيرا ان الثقافه المحليه
مثل مثل ثقافات الشعوب الاخرى فيها عادات
وتقاليد تشهد او تعبر عن انفتاح
عالي على الاخر لا يوازيه اي انفتاح
وهذا اللي كنت احاول ان اكشف عنها في
الضيافه اطروحه الضيافه هذا الانسان
المضياف
انا وانت ننتمي تقريبا لعادات متشابهه
ومتقاربه الناس
لماذا يقدسون الباب المفتوح لماذا يقدسون
لماذا يتوقفون عن سؤال الضيف عن اسمه
الا احترازا من ان يكون ان تكون هذه
الضيافه مشروطه بمن انت بهويتك وكانهم
يقولون سنرحب بك مهما كنت ايا كنت بل ان
الصح وحاولت ان تفسدها لانها تدخل فيها
المعايير الدينيه وهي وهي عادات تتجاوز كل
الاختلافات بين البشر الاختلافات العرقيه
والاختلافات الدينيه والاختلافات فالضيافه
انا يعني حاولت انه في هذا الكتاب ان
نحللها طبعا مستخدما المنهج الفينيمولوجي
ظاهراتي ان احلل هذه العلاقه بين الذات
والاخر من خلال مشهد الضيافه الذي يكشف عن
انفتاح على الاخر
بدون شروط انكشاف مدهش ومذهل ويخرج
الانسان من من النمط الوجود اللي يمكن
تصوره او تعبير عنها بالوجود من اجل الذات
الى الوجود من اجل الاخر هذا انفتاح طبعا
الناس كان الضيافه
للاجنبي وللغريب وللمختلف والعبر السبيل
لم تكن لمن يشبهنا وهذا هذا هذا هو
هذا ما افسده افسد لاحقا لكن هي الضيافه
نفسها هي موقف ترحيب واستقبال مخصص للاخر
وليس للقريب